estar a la escucha cueste lo que cueste
de la angustia de los estudiantes
esa es la misión que tiene la asociación
nightline cada noche estos jóvenes
brindan su tiempo de manera voluntaria
ofrecen escuchar en francés o en inglés
de manera anónima y sin juzgar a los
estudiantes que tienen necesidad de
hablar con alguien
son muchísimos los temas que abordan
quienes nos llaman muy amplios las
personas nos llaman por todo tipo de
razones ahora hay unos temas que se
tocan con más frecuencia como son el
aislamiento el estrés los estudios las
amistades las relaciones amorosas las
relaciones familiares y ahora el cob y
la pandemia las medidas relacionadas con
esta con el acompañamiento de
estudiantes por estudiantes también está
siendo experimentado por los cruz este
organismo público que vela por el
bienestar de los universitarios puso en
marcha referentes kobe en sus
residencias estudiantes
como niños somos un referente en el seno
de los estudiantes entonces si los
estudiantes tienen un problema vienen
primero a vernos a nosotros porque
nosotros estamos con ellos estamos más
cerca de ellos yo soy un estudiante como
los demás es mucho más simple ir a
hablar con un vecino que ir a una
oficina oa la administración que puede
ser más complicado en lo inmediato de
administración
simon anholt sociales y bueno también
tenemos un rol social hablamos con los
estudiantes nos reunimos con ellos
aprendemos a conocerlos
sin embargo actuar contra la desazón
requiere también de un profesional los
servicios de medicina universitaria en
especial de ayuda psicológica son
estructuras en donde los estudiantes
también pueden encontrar apoyo